[Music]
in bury the evidence news that's I used
to do with my report and then he didn't
I found my old report card pretty bad
all the hoes like ffff ffff ffff dee dee
dee dee dee and then you start seeing a
little change might be a fantastic
dynamite there you go
I never had an ass before you know you
never took Spanish then dude I had a
d-minus at most but getting an F is
really hard I took Spanish for four
years and I barely made it out of there
dude
I got a F because I didn't go to class
there you go submitted by my name is
inigo montoya hi I don't get the
reference you know like really a
landscaper is being accused of murdering
at least five people and burying their
remains in large flower planters oh he
was using him for fertilizer pretty good
I got a lot of fish that died in my fish
tank and then I put it inside my garden
and I planted on top of them that was
some awesome [ __ ] oh yeah cuz that would
be fertilizer right yeah I think they
used to do that back in a day when it
grew corn did you chop up the fish first
or just whole thing no way man I just do
it in there those are your buddies it's
heart disease no like [ __ ] death no
cook the the soil over it it doesn't
smell like fish yet okay it kind of oh
okay that's the scientific experiments
birthday yeah lobster shells and [ __ ] in
the back back of the days that's the
show with us with a date plan event
boxes no cuz I lobster was like peasant
food and so they would take that you use
all the remains and though all those
shellfish or whatever they're just used
some hmm some random fact that I know I
don't know why I like crab better
we need a David random back lever he's
pulling you guys just that late at night
you just read one thing and you want to
know why [ __ ] lots are so expensive
they tell you was peasant food back in
the day somebody told me that lobsters
scream while they die they do
I looked it up it's there shall
releasing [ __ ] pressure thanks
apparently incredibly painful for them
okay we wanna ban lobster I forgot which
country live lobster killing yeah [ __ ]
Bechet is more delicious that way yeah
that's true Asian countries gonna pass
that yeah cuz I saw Gordon Ramsay he
goes when you have the lobster put the
knife in the back of his head and slice
like whites throw it in the water
oh wait Gordon Ramsay believes in doing
that that [ __ ] yeah
he doesn't just throw it in the water
you see that have you seen the video
that [ __ ] on YouTube is what he just
dismembers the whole [ __ ] hundred
percent amazing and it's weird too
because it's almost like he named it
first like it looks like it's a sick
little buddy he like perhaps at first
and [ __ ] and he's just all of a sudden
just things in the back of his skull
just brains everywhere this is all too
bald right exactly
[ __ ] was nuts man yeah story though okay
kind of so his name is so this dude his
name is Bruce McArthur 66 years old from
Toronto Toronto Wow
I thought they didn't have crime there
he is being accused of being a serial
killer let's see how polite he looks he
doesn't even look like a serial killer
his eyebrows are cool he's got dead eyes
there's nothing circles are jolly he
looks like dr. Jeff he was also like a
mall Santa he looks like it for sure he
did he raped his victims or he was just
a okay like a killer like I just kill so
it seems to me that he was in the gay
community and he please a gay killer was
killing his oh come on buddy
because of jealousy at least one of his
victims work was his lover I think this
is what happened he's all like he's all
like if if I can't have you then no one
can and then he kills the lover yeah so
these are the victims that they've
discovered so far
they all look weird as [ __ ] he type it
was weird as [ __ ] he likes the Middle
Eastern men huh
oh it's only one guy that's not a mug
shot in the middle part of the bill they
all do this with the eyebrows they're
all doing that they're all kind of weird
if they all have a scowl yeah from over
here the middle that looks like a young
Keanu Reeves and then the one to the
right is like Jon Bernthal guys man that
sucks they never saw coming
that's my first Jon Bernthal reference
interpreted I like it since he became in
the big time are there details on how he
did it so initially they brought a man
in connection with two missing men and
they found a dismembered remains of
these victims in large planters on
properties linked to this landscaper was
he afraid that it was gonna smell I told
you that Shh if I do it Jone soil on top
you don't smell [ __ ] but how big are
your fish is compared to like limbs when
it cut limbs up and so far they were
like multiple limbs and large bore
defense for a soil it don't spoil okay
how would you put it next to your job it
was like this big
that's like he gives the properties I
worked on my leave bodies there to move
I think that's gonna decompose this guy
hadn't even seen one episode of Law &
Order yeah you know anything like
consider Dexter's level [ __ ] Dexter I
consider like more advanced at college
level mm-hmm to me like law and order's
like you know for everyone
I just pictured him like putting his
victims on the grass and then moving
like the lawn mower over there
I thought that's how he killed his
victims just like flesh and flannels
hydaburg well like a weed whacker and
then the guys you need to make a harm
like I'd watch her I don't like scary
movies no would you get rid of a body if
you killed it it's secrecy
Oh chop it up into pieces and put it
down a drain of course why not feed it
to your dog [ __ ] - you know what I mean
that is a good idea though or it's not a
protein company and then grind it up and
then sell it in supplements yeah I
wouldn't even know how to give it such a
large piece of animal I would probably
like if I first kill someone I'd
probably back them up and just drive
into the middle of nowhere like BLM land
and then drive off the road and then do
all the chopping and all that stuff
there Wow because then they're really
far away and then from that point on a
plan what I'll do well what if you kill
them in your house I come in the house
I'm putting in the bat in the plastic
bag I didn't you're leaving your house
I'm leaving my house immediately I'm
leaving it immediately and then drying
it off halfway to Vegas I'm staying at
home cuz I got something called a toilet
and I could flush it a million times but
they'll find like bone I'll find
something
are you sure they'll find it you just
let it decompose in that acid [ __ ] but
you can't even get the acid [ __ ]
anywhere if you haven't written a line
people weigh the acid in the in a drain
in polluters waters how [ __ ] horrible
oh yeah but you're not gonna [ __ ]
judge me for the murder ages committed
I'm assuming you killed the PO that
person was trying to sexually assault
you so yeah it's okay yeah so hope it's
chilly you got to remember it doesn't
make sense I'd want to get rid of the
body I would just had like he wanted a
it's self-defense I'm not dumb you don't
know you're gonna put and you're gonna
trust your life to the jury of your
peers
I mean I'm a woman right now the best
time to be a woman all right yeah why
would this handsome man attack you God
hey man I'm a white straight male dude
I'm going down no matter what no matter
what man be careful you better believe
I'm taking to a [ __ ] volcano I stand
by my theory that if you take a body to
a volcano there is no way for someone to
find out that you killed that first yo
get that Hill up [ __ ] die on it I'm
gonna dial Anila hey know if you think
about it if you put some [ __ ] into labor
they're not getting anywhere either
you're gonna do what is it you know you
chuck it into labor but you took it yeah
but Africa loss enough to even Chuck
you're melting too you know but no you
dismember the body in such a way where
you can throw it at a bunch of bowling
bags right like each by each body part
goes in like one Bowl that you work
buddy come on and you're gonna throw it
off the hell isn't enough work that you
never want to get it you want to get
away with murder for your life how many
feet deep in your throat buddy I threw a
shotput make it was [ __ ] nothing
I do that [ __ ] on the shop what is you
have really good grip bro [ __ ] did I do
that no problem no problem you better
believe it
by the way to never get that knock on
the door like that means you gotta
travel all the way to Hawaii just to do
email not just Hawaii there's one up
button Washington yeah there it is
there's a live volcano in Washington I
love is live but if you go deep enough
anything's live dude in volcano and
that's the truth that's the goddamn
volcano land was rough man it's just
gonna be you dumping a [ __ ] body onto
a mountain we found this idiot with a
bunch of body parts going up a mountain
oh you could be like the old school mob
and then like cement their legs and then
go sleep with the fishes and you throw
them over that seems like it works right
in my head and all the mackerel come and
eat up the body and then it disappeared
that works life here's a good question
somebody asked me this and they looked
at me like I was crazy
have you guys ever thought about
murdering somebody before all the time I
did before yeah he's pretty common if
you watch one of those shows you kind of
play along you know somebody pisses you
off you're like I could [ __ ] murder
you right now yeah sometimes I think
about people that I love that I murder
but then it's like I don't want to think
about that but my brain doesn't let me
stop some thoughts should be private
thoughts like when you wake up early in
the morning and your brain catches you
off guard and you're like why I'm I
think about that right now your brain
catches what what catches you it's it
starts thinking for me and I don't want
to think that way but it just keeps
going and then I realized that I'm
thinking about something that I don't
want to think about like murdering
people that are close to me next week in
a real player
[Music]